Well,
let's,
let's turn to a page
five 27 in your anthology
where you find a famous
poem by Wilfred Owen
called Bell K at Decorum S.
And uh,
your footnote explains,
that's that phrase is the beginning of
a line from Horace completed at the end
of the poem,
uh,
that isn't the last lines of
the palm pro Patrizia Mori,
uh,
translated as a,
it is sweet and proper sweeten right
decorous to die for one's country.
Bent double like old beggars under sacks,
knock kneed coughing like hags.
We cursed from sludge till
on the haunting flares.
We turned our backs and towards
our distant rest began to trudge.
Men Marched Asleep.
Many had lost their boots,
but limped on bloodshot.
Yeah,
all went lame.
All blind drunk with fatigue,
death even to the hoots of tired out
stripped five nines that dropped behind
gas,
gas quick boys.
An ecstasy of fumbling fitting
the clumsy helmets just in time,
but someone's still was yelling,
yelling out and stumbling and
floundering like a man in fire or lime,
dim through the misty pains and
thick green light as under a green.
See,
I saw him drowning
in all my dreams before my helpless site.
He plunges at me.
Guttering, choking, drowning.
Yeah.
If in some smothering dreams,
you too could pace behind the
wagon that we flung him in.
Okay.
And watch the white eyes
writhing in his face,
his hanging face like
a devil's sick of sin.
If you could hear at every jolt,
the blood come gargling from the froth,
corrupted lungs,
obscene as cancer,
bitter as the cud of vile,
incurable sores on innocent tongues.
My friend,
you would not tell with
such high zest to children,
ardent for some desperate glory,
the old lie Dole k at the core.
I'm asked Cro.
Patrizia Maury.
Okay.
Paul Fussell,
uh,
a literary critic who wrote
a brilliant book about,
uh,
the literature and,
uh, uh, culture, uh, of,
of the first world war.
Uh, he speaks of irony as, as the, uh,
essential trope or rhetorical figure,
uh,
of this body of literature,
World War One poetry.
Uh, here is in this poem, uh, a, uh, uh,
example of irony of a really
comparatively simple kind,
uh,
what our school by school boy
lines from Horace Lines that, uh,
oh, and then many others would
have learned in school, uh,
to recite, uh, to have memorized that,
uh,
poetry is here held up
as propaganda, uh, as,
as a,
as a kind of murderous lie.
It is sweet and right to
die for one's country.
Uh, uh, you, you, you,
you can feel it in the marvelous
texture of this poetry,
uh,
against horses decorous and elegant Latin,
there is placed Owen's Anglo
Saxon alliterative inflected,
strongly stressed, uh, language,
uh, with, it's a rough,
uh, and, uh, actual, uh,
vernacular diction.
Uh,
the power and authority to, of, of, uh,
uh, Owens writing, uh,
is well certified. We feel, uh,
by that first person, uh, that
speaks to us, that, that I,
who speaks from as a, as
a witness, uh, to, uh,
war, uh, as a describer, uh,
as someone telling a reader elsewhere,
uh, what he has seen in
speaking specifically for,
uh,
one fallen soldier.
Uh,
the reception of Owen's poetry
has always been attached to,
um, uh, a sense of, oh,
and as a soldier and witness to war,
uh,
and indeed as a victim
of war, uh, who, uh, uh,
died a week before the armistice.
Uh,
this, uh, these poems, uh,
that you see the cover for here,
um,
excuse me, poems by Wilfred Owen, uh,
originally appeared posthumously,
uh, uh, after, uh, uh,
Owens death, uh, introduced by Sigrid Sas,
soon a comrade fellow
poet, fellow soldier. Uh,
and, and as you can see, uh, it, uh,
in addition to the introduction, um, uh,
the cover advertises also
a portrait of the art,
not a portrait of the artist at portrait
of the author. And there is oh and, uh,
in uniform, uh, a handsome young man.
Um, this is, uh, all, as I say,
very much part of the
transmission of Owen's poetry.
A doll k et decorum asked,
uh, is a, is a great poem.
But the kind of irony that it puts
forward is I think a simple one.
Uh, it is, uh, well, and it's
a poem. There are lots of them,
uh, that are, are great poems, uh, that
when I first started teaching this course,
I decided I wouldn't teach. Uh,
and, and for a number of reasons,
uh, including, um, well,
uh, the sense that, uh,
g Yates, Steven's, uh, uh, Elliot, these,
they're hard poets and we need as
much time on them as we can, uh, in,
in order to read their work.
And, and, uh, this poem,
uh, seemed, uh,
like one you might find and
be able to read yourself,
uh, without me there to explain it. Um,
it also is the case that probably probably
many of you have already read it, uh,
and possibly studied it in school
and talked about it. So, at any rate,
this seemed to me to be, uh, when
I started teaching this course. Um,
uh, you know, uh, uh, reasons
not to teach it, uh, besides,
besides, uh, well, I think the
first time I taught this course,
uh, the, uh, um, well, uh,
was a few years after the Gulf War,
the first Gulf War. Uh,
and, uh, it seemed, uh,
to me, uh, in, in my, uh,
historical innocence that, uh, uh,
the irony that,
uh,
Owen is playing upon here,
that he's putting forward to us, uh, was,
was not one that I would need to
talk about a in a classroom. Uh,
it seemed to me, uh, as though, uh,
no one would ever quote Horace
again as anything but a lie.
Um, of course, that's not the case. Uh,
you know, uh, as our present, uh,
war has gone on.
Uh,
how many times have we heard people,
uh,
you know, in many different
forms, uh, speaking, uh,
of justification for the
death of young men and women,
uh, on behalf of the nation? Well, um,
uh, you know, uh, as
we watch our, our, um,
as we watch our president's approval
ratings for his conduct of the war drop,
uh, one wonders, well,
could any of us really
be surprised by this? Uh,
and we'll,
uh,
certainly Wilfred Owen
would not have been. Uh,
and it seemed to me as
though, uh, in fact, uh,
it was important to read
well for doe and, and to, uh,
go on thinking and talking about his
poetry and not only own of course,
but, uh, really the extraordinary,
uh,
rich body of British World War One poetry,
as a whole, uh, writing that
is not by any means, uh,
all about battle though.
Much of it is like that poem I just read,
uh,
today when I want to do is give you
have some sense of this body of writing.
Uh,
and unlike a,
the last few lectures where I've
concentrated on a single poet and,
and tried to make arguments about,
uh, that poet and, and have, uh,
you know, thesis. Uh,
today what I want to do is really
just show you different poems, uh,
and different, uh, poets.
Uh, you know, a range of, of,
uh, uh, brilliant, uh, writing, um,
in addition to an opportunity
to think about poetry and war.
Uh,
it's also a good opportunity to start
to fill out a little bit our sense of,
of what modern poetry is or, uh, was, um,
uh,
what it is or was
also what it did not
become a world war one,
uh, destroyed, uh, in
English generation. Um,
you know, uh, modern poetry as we
study it in this class. And,
uh, you know, I think, uh, as,
as you see it in this, this anthology
is an international phenomenon.
It's not, uh, um, well, uh,
we don't have a lot of English
poets on his syllabus. Um,
there is a ts Eliot,
uh,
the only great English
poet born in America. Uh,
there is, uh, uh, wh Auden, uh,
in English born poet who moved to America.
Uh,
most of the figures that we study
are in fact Americans. Uh, there's,
there's Yates to, uh, all of them
are in a sense internationals.
Uh, and there, there's
a, uh, uh, you know,
a range of,
of important cultural reasons for this,
but there's also the simple fact
of, of the war. Uh, arguably, uh,
the great modern English
poets died, uh, in,
in the teens in France in 1915 and 1917.
Uh, or, uh, they survived, uh,
like Ivor Gurney who you have some
samples from in a wounded, uh,
and, and, uh, um, uh, injured, uh, state.
Um,
I also think it's important for us to
think about the war, uh, as, as,
um, uh, an important context,
uh, when we go on to read
pound and Elliot, uh,
when we, uh, encounter,
uh, in their poetry,
a sense of a apocalyptic, uh, change,
uh, of civilization in crisis, which
can seem pretty vague sometimes.
Uh, well, um,
and this is true for the Yates poems
that we've been talking about as well.
A Yates is obviously writing, uh, in
the context of an Irish civil war,
but it's also the case that
he's riding in the, uh,
a shadow of the first world
war as well. Uh, you know,
uh, on July 1st, 1916, uh,
more than a 57,000 English troops,
uh, were, uh, wounded or dead, uh, uh,
I think, uh, almost
20,000 on that day, um,
died. And, uh, in the, in
the battle of the Somme, um,
as it unfolded, uh, there were
a million casualties. Uh, this,
this is a, you know, a
scale of, of, uh, uh,
human suffering, uh, and, and, uh, uh, um,
uh, kind of, um, well, uh,
a scale of human suffering that is
enormous and hard to comprehend and leaves
its shadow across the writing
that we will be reading.
Uh, I, uh,
all the parts we will be
talking about today are men.
Uh, not quite all soldiers,
but most of them, uh,
I've given you some quotes, um, uh,
from Virginia Woolf,
uh,
partly to remind us that,
the war did not only exist
for men, uh, or soldiers,
uh, and that it existed in
England, uh, as quite as,
uh,
much as it existed on the continent.
Uh, well, uh, w with all of
that, uh, said by preparation.
Uh, let me show you some more poems. Um,
beginning with Thomas Hardy
on page 51,
hardy is, uh, this is, this is, uh,
a little pamphlet, uh, of, uh,
war pumps hardy published, uh, in, um,
1917. And that, that, um, uh,
you can find in the binary, keep
a hardy,
arguably the greatest English poet,
um, modern English poet, uh, is,
is a figure we don't study in
this course. Otherwise. Uh,
he is a poet from another
century. He's born, uh,
in fact, 20 years before
the American civil war, uh,
when World War One
began, uh, he was 74. Uh,
he wrote a, his poems from
the perspective of, uh,
uh, the rural England. That was the
setting for almost all of his novels,
almost all of his poetry,
uh,
and channel firing on the
bottom of 51, uh, is, um,
uh, also set in the west of England, uh,
Hardy's home country, uh, and, uh, is,
is set right on the verge
of the first World War.
It's a poem about gunnery
practice. Uh, yeah.
Uh, it's a, it's a,
a dramatic monologue spoken by one of
the dead in a graveyard that night.
Your great guns unawares shook all our
coffins as we lay and broke the chancel
window squares.
We thought it was the judgment
day and sat up. Right.
I heard it already has.
It has.
It has various gothic and supernatural
fancies that he asks us to imagine and
vivid homely terms.
While dreary some arose,
the howl of wakened towns,
this is all is this wonderful
observed detail of rural life.
The mouse let fall the altar crumb,
the worms drew back into the mountains.
The Glebe cow drooled
till God called.
No,
it's gunnery practice out at sea.
Just as before you went below
the world is as it used to be.
This is not the second coming
all knit kind of reply to Yates.
Although Yates hasn't written this poem.
Yup.
All nation striving strong
to make red war yet redder,
mad as hatters they do no
more for Christie Sake.
Then you who are helpless in such matters
that this is not the judgment hour for
some of them is a blessing thing for if
it were that have to scour health floor
for so much threatening.
Ha Ha was hard.
He's God laughs like that.
It will be frostbit have understood it.
Uh,
it will be warmer when I blow the trumpet.
If indeed I ever do for you are men
and rest eternal. Sorely need this.
This is God so cruel that he will not
deliver the Second Coming Day of Judgment.
So down we lay again.
I wonder,
will the world ever seen her be said one?
Then when he sent us under
in our indifferent century,
in many,
a skeleton shook his head.
Instead of preaching 40 year,
my neighbor Parson thirdly said,
I wish I had stuck to pipes and beer
again.
The guns disturb the hour,
roaring their readiness to event as far
inland distort and tower and Camelot and
starlet Stonehenge.
Okay.
Gunnery practice, uh, disturbs
the dead, uh, disrupts the ground.
Uh, you know, here, here, war refuses
to let the deadline piece, uh,
with the notion that not even
the dead are safe from it,
unaffected by it.
Uh,
the church windows shatter well
in some sense,
this is exactly what modernity might be
seen to be doing to traditional English
culture. Uh, heart hardy is,
is full of all this quaint,
Gothic, uh, archaic, uh, Dixon's, uh, and,
and fancies,
uh,
the dead or raising their
objections here to two guns, uh, uh,
that will be a used very
shortly in the great war.
God reassures them though, of
course, what he says here is,
is not reassuring.
Uh,
he says that although red
war is getting redder,
it's really as it always has been.
Uh,
this is not the end of the
world that it appears to be a,
he's not about to let Manheim mankind
off the hook with Judgment Day.
Uh, the speaker narrate or
lies back, uh, and wonders, uh,
if the world will ever be
saner. Uh, his neighbor,
uh, says, well, I don't
think so. I wish I had, uh,
uh, you know, pleasured myself
and, uh, uh, rather than,
uh, serving that, uh, wicked God,
uh,
in the last stanza,
then there is that extraordinary
shift of perspective.
Uh, the sound of the
guns carries inland, uh,
into the heart of England.
Uh, and as it does,
it carries back also in time to
Camelot and to starlet Stonehenge.
Uh,
what happens when that happens?
What is the meaning of, of
this, the power of this,
of the sound of the guns to,
to echo back in time,
uh,
as hardy evokes Camelot and stonehengey.
You might, you might, uh, read
this, understand this says, um,
as,
as what,
as dignifying and legitimate
dating the present,
uh,
present firing the present conflict
or in some sense does it go just the
opposite? Does it, uh,
does it suggest that England's history
and its heritage and its honor,
uh,
are in jeopardy?
Uh,
uh,
does it in some sense
demythologize the past,
demystify it,
make us see Camelot and Stonehenge
as part of a bear barbaric,
uh, uh, history, um, uh,
such as is about to unfold in 1914.
Uh, there are a couple other, uh,
hardy poems in your anthology,
uh, memorable and powerful, uh,
that are war poems, uh, including, uh,
on page 59 in the time of
the breaking of nations.
And then on the next page, uh,
I looked up from my writing,
interesting to look at
these together. Uh, in,
in the first poem,
a hardy affirms the endurance
of rural life, and it's,
it's cycles.
Only a man harrowing.
Claude's
in a slow,
silent walk with an old
horse that stumbles and nods
half asleep as they stock.
Yeah.
Only thin smoke without flame
from the heaps of couch grass,
yet this will go on word the same though.
Dynasties pass,
okay.
Beyond or a maid and her
white come whispering by wars,
analysts will fade in tonight,
air their story, die. Uh,
rural life including, uh, um,
rituals of love and courtship,
uh,
here are represented as poetry's truest
subject and as a kind of enduring,
uh, uh, source of, of, um,
uh, social life and meaning, uh,
you could compare this poem to,
uh, the poem place last and,
and Yates is, uh, uh, last
poems called politics. Uh,
that might seem to say something similar,
uh,
in hardy here. And in
other pumps, there's, uh,
the serve wonderfully self,
consciously archaic language.
Uh, hardy wants to use really old, uh,
dialect words when he can. Um, and,
and there's, there's, there's,
there's power in that.
And this is a poem composed in 1915,
uh,
when we read the love song of J.
Dot.
Alfred Prufrock when we
read pounds first Canto, uh,
remember that those poems are written,
published at just the same time.
This poem is being written,
uh,
palms with a very different, um, uh,
ways of, of proceeding, uh, in
different kinds of language. Uh,
in the second poem here, I looked
up from my riding, uh, the poet,
the first person is being interrupted
a at his desk, uh, at night.
Uh, he's, he, uh, his startled, uh,
to see the moon's full gaze on me.
Uh,
her meditative misty head was
spectral and it's there and I,
and voluntarily said,
what are you doing there?
And Hardy Hardy works in these,
uh, song forms that, well,
they sound like popular
ballads. Uh, and, and he, he,
he wants you to, uh, uh, you know,
hear them as part of almost a kind of
folk literature, which he draws on.
Uh, the, uh, Moon says to him, Oh,
I've been scanning pat pond and whole
and waterway hear about for the body of
one with a sunken soul who
has put his life flight out.
Did you hear his frenzy tattle?
It was sorrow for his son who
is slain and brutish battle,
though he has injured none.
Okay.
And now the moon says,
I am curious to look into the blinkered
mind poet of one who wants to write a
book in a world of such a kind
her temper.
The poet then says,
overwrought me in I edge
to sh to shun her view,
to get out of the moonlight for I felt
assured she thought me one who should
drown him to, uh, here. Uh,
a neighbor father, a crazed with
grief at the death of his son,
uh, has drowned himself,
uh, uh, killed himself.
Uh, and the moon, uh, implies, uh,
in its gaze that the
poet should do so too.
Uh, in such a world, uh,
it seems writing poems
is, is a, a kind of, well,
even surviving as a kind
of guilty privilege.
You could compare with this
poem a Kipling's. Uh, uh, poem,
a Kipling, one of the great
apologists of empire, uh,
saying on page one 53 of,
of your, your book, uh,
in the voice of a soldier,
a if any question why we soldiers died,
tell them our father's lied.
Uh,
a statement that is, uh,
uh, poignant, uh, uh,
pointing and powerful in part because
Kipling's own son died in the war.
This is the volume of poems
published in 1917 by Edward Thomas
and a portrait of Thomas,
another soldier, poet, uh,
not represented. However, as a
soldier here, uh, represented,
uh, rather as a, uh, uh,
English citizen in Tweed,
a man out,
in and of nature.
Thomas born in 1878.
So he was 36 when the war began.
He began almost at the same time
as the war began to write poems.
Uh, he begins writing, uh,
under the influence of
his friend Robert Frost.
Frost and Thomas have a
fascinating relationship, uh,
an important, uh, transatlantic
exchange, uh, for us.
Famous poem, the road
less traveled by, uh,
he,
uh,
sometimes described as being about Thomas
and Thomas' own sense of regret and
hesitation and indirection.
Uh,
to which frost contest it himself.
frost became an England, uh,
uh, a poet of New England
whom Thomas was reading at that moment
in such a way as to help enable him,
Thomas to become a great poet of England,
uh,
and of England's, uh, uh, landscape and,
and countryside, uh, and uh, nature.
Uh, there are, um, there,
there's a good selection from
Thomas, uh, in your anthology. Uh,
I will, uh, read my
favorite poem by Thomas,
uh,
which is the first one called adol strop
on to 31.
Uh,
yes,
I remember adults strop
the name because one afternoon of heat,
the express train drew
up their unwantedly.
It was late June,
the steam hist
someone cleared his throat,
no one left and no one
came on the bear platform.
What I saw was adol strop
only the name and willows,
willow herb and grass and
meadow sweet and hey Cox dry,
no witless less still and lonely.
Fair than the high cloudlets in the sky.
And for that minute,
a blackbird saying close by in round
him mistier farther and farther,
all the birds of Oxford Shear
in Gloucestershire year.
It's a wonderful poem in its simplicity,
modesty,
directness and
reticence,
which yet provides the most expansive
and exhilarating a since of the English
landscape and of the power
of a moment in time to uh,
uh, enlarge and, and, uh, be uh,
pregnant with meaning a notice,
a notice Thomas's really
superb nonchalance and
offhandedness and simplicity.
It was late June.
The steam hist.
I mean, there, there's a kind of a
colloquial clarity and confidence, uh,
quite different from the,
uh,
vernacular language in um,
the hardy palms. I was just reading,
which are also poems of the countryside.
A here, the name, the name that odd name,
adults strop prompts a memory,
prompts a memory in such a way
that a moment in time stands out,
separated from other moments just as
the odd and poetic and beautiful name
adults strop seems to stand out there.
There's a kind of poignant pension
between the beautifulness of the name,
the awkwardness, and yet
the dignity of the name, uh,
and the sense of natural beauty
that the poem will unfold
here.
The stopping of the train is like the,
the interruption by memory
of normal consciousness.
That's the basis of the poem.
There's a sense that in this memory
of the poet, somehow saw the name
presumably, I suppose, saw
it on a sign board, uh, in,
in the,
uh,
station as you roll into a
station and you see where you are.
Uh, but there's, there's more
suggestion in it than that.
Uh,
it says if this moment we're one
in which the name and the place,
the word and the thing,
uh, fully coincided,
uh, fully coincided in
a experience of, of, uh,
uh, uh, presence and,
and immediacy where the
world is all there. Uh, and,
and named, located, placed, uh,
the figure,
the metaphor for this semiotic unity of,
of word and thing, uh, is bird song. Uh,
hear bird song a is a
kind of natural language,
a language in which nature speaks,
uh, and speaks in such a way,
uh, that the particular voice
carries a, the import and, uh,
authority of the general, uh, uh, just as,
as the one bird seems to sing with many
bird's songs by the end of the palm.
And so adults strap itself suddenly seems
to signify more a calling to mind in
the kind of rippling and
radiating circles. Uh, uh,
Oxford Sheer Gloucester
sheer, uh, England,
all of it,
the poet's home.
Uh,
at the same time,
it's also clear that this epiphany
is a remembered experience.
It's recalled, uh, the
poet's first word, yes,
wonderful affirmation.
Ah,
situates the poem in a dialogue
as if someone had just said,
have you ever been to adults strap,
uh,
whether this dialogue is, is,
you know, actual or in internal,
it doesn't really matter.
Uh,
the pump part of the poems
forced derives from, uh, uh,
the, uh, status of this moment
is something remembered, uh,
and remembered, um, uh,
within the context of a nation at war.
Although I believe, uh,
Thomas wrote the palm, uh,
the year he enlisted. But I
think before his enlistment, uh,
you might feel as though Thomas
is already on the train, uh,
for France. Uh, there,
there's a way in which the context
of the war to shadows the poem,
uh, and, and remains
present in it. Um, uh,
don't you feel it? Uh,
in certain, uh, details,
uh,
the Erie lack of people in this place,
no one left and no one came.
Uh,
in a sense,
uh,
it is an image of the English countryside
at a moment in which it is being
emptied out. Uh, uh,
it's young men sent to France to
die a kind of no man's land already.
This is Siegfried soon in uniform,
uh,
in 1916,
Sas soons poetry,
uh,
centers on a hallucinatory overlays
of homefront and battlefront.
Let's look at blighters on,
on page three 89,
uh,
a
wonderfully angry poem.
Uh,
a poem that is situated in a music hall,
I guess,
presumably a London Music Hall.
The House has crammed tier beyond tier.
They grin and cackle at the show
while prancing ranks of harlots,
shrill,
the chorus drunk with dyn.
We're sure the Kaiser
loves the dear old tanks.
I'd like to see a tank come down the
stalls lurching to ragtime tunes or home
sweet home.
And there'd be no more jokes
in musicals to mock the riddle.
Corpses Round Bowl Palm.
Okay.
Here,
there's an analogy between the
music hall and the theater of war.
Uh,
it's as if the English populous were
spectators only consuming as entertainment
war propaganda,
which makes the poet hate them.
He imagines here the eruption of the real,
uh,
into this representational space, uh, and,
and imagines it as a kind
of attack on the, uh, uh,
working in middleclass audiences of the,
of the music hall. Uh, the, the, uh,
the soldier becomes a in fantasy here,
uh,
the spectator as the war turns
around and comes back, uh, uh,
reversed by kind of evil charm
or spell, uh, coming home
and home is here made to
rhyme with [inaudible],
uh,
bringing battlefront and
homefront together as a rhyme.
Uh,
there,
there's an aggression towards the urban
crowd here that recalls and exaggerates
a Yates his attitude at the same
time, uh, really in the same, uh,
years, uh, in poems like
a coat or the fishermen
in other Sasoon poems,
the, the war comes home.
And in other ways, uh, for example,
uh, well, uh, in the rear guard, uh,
just just down the page here,
uh,
or repression of war experience,
which is about a
traumatic repetition of, uh,
uh, battle, uh, or in dreamers, uh, where,
um, there is, um, uh, again,
a kind of juxtaposing of a life in
the trenches in life in the city,
uh,
rather than dwell longer on them though.
And to make sure I get time
for a couple more poems,
I want to move on and,
uh,
consider this is a festoons poem,
poems, um, counter attack.
And this is the poetry of Isaac Rosenberg.
Uh, here's a frontest piece
with, with Rosenberg in a,
a, um, a military coat.
A Rosenberg was all besides a poet,
was also an artist,
uh, and, uh, uh, created
these self portraits,
self portrait in France in 1915.
Uh,
Rosenberg in contrast to Sasoon was poor.
Uh, Jewish, uh,
and rights are rather different kind of
poem from those we have been looking at
today. Uh, one of the most famous, uh,
and extraordinary is Laos
hunting on page five oh six,
a little bit further on in your book.
Okay.
Nudes stark and glistening,
yelling and Lurid [inaudible] grinning
faces and raging limbs were all over the
floor. One fire for a
shirt. Verminous Lee,
busy yon soldier tour
from his throat with oath.
God had might shrink app but not the lice.
And soon the shirt was a flare over
the candle. He'd lit while we lay.
Then we all sprang up and stripped
to hunt. The verminous brewed
here. The, the soldiers are, uh,
stripping their clothes off and,
and, and attacking the lice
that are attacking them
soon like a demon's pantomime.
The place was raging.
It's nighttime and, and, and the
candles and flares, they're throwing
shadows. See the silhouettes of gate.
See the Jib bring shadows mixed
with the battled arms on the wall.
See Gargantuan hooked fingers.
Pluck in supreme flesh to
smuch supreme littleness.
See the Mary limbs and hot Highland
fling because some wizard vermin charmed
from the quiet.
This rebel when our ears,
we're half load by the dark
music blown from sleeps trumpet,
a strange place for this poem to end.
Uh,
nudes, the poem begins.
Uh, it's a, uh, uh,
shocking, uh, and, and,
and comic and pleasurable
to see the armored men.
Uniformed men suddenly
exposed just naked bodies
to see them, uh, here.
Bedeviled not by a gas
attack or machine guns,
but lice,
fleas,
uh,
Rosenberg is writing,
not in those little
crafted stands as of um,
hardy or of, um, for that
matter of Thomas, uh,
he's riding in a kind
of strongly stressed,
a free verse with a variable line lengths.
Uh, lots of, uh, well the, the,
there's a sense in which the poetry
itself is exuberant and naked and full of
life and, uh, by uh, vital, uh,
and naturalistic,
you could say in its
representation.
Uh,
Rosenberg is giving us an
anecdote from the trenches
and yet it's slips very
quickly into a sense of fable.
Uh, uh, the, the louse hunting
where these big men hunt these
little things, these fleas,
uh, it becomes, uh,
when it's thrown by shadow as it kind of
flickering image on the tent or trench
wall, uh, uh, when it becomes
represented, so to speak. Uh, it,
it becomes a battle scene where gigantic
forces smuch supreme littleness.
We are put in mind of how men
are to the gods as flies to men.
Uh, this is an analogy as old as
and found in homer [inaudible].
Uh, we are also put in mind
of how the wars, in fact,
anything but a revel,
a though it too may have been provoked
by a cause as insignificant and hard to
trace as some wizard vermin.
Uh,
those last lines then are
so ominous and strange.
Uh, though these men have been
brought to life, uh, from sleep,
uh,
there's a sense that the trumpet
will sound for them again.
Uh, and they will enter a dark
sleep from which they won't wake a,
which is just the, the point
of, uh, the next poem, uh,
returning.
We hear the Larks,
I won't take time to read it though.
Uh, or, or talk about it. Uh,
but instead,
uh,
I'd like to conclude
this is, uh, another, uh,
great poet of the war who
survived though, um, uh, in,
as I say, uh, uh, uh, wounded, uh, uh,
condition mentally Ivor Gurney.
Uh,
I want to conclude with a,
uh,
a poem by Owen. Um, there's, uh,
let's see. This is, this is page five, 28,
uh,
just following Dulcie at decorum asked,
uh, strange meeting. Uh,
this is a poem that,
um,
well, uh, if the first
poem demystifies, um, uh,
one crucial threat of war ideology,
uh,
that it is right and good
to die for the country. Uh,
this poem takes on, uh, another, uh,
crucial element of war ideology that,
uh,
the enemy is another,
the enemy is unlike me.
Uh, like Rosenberg, uh,
like a Rosenberg's poem.
Uh,
this one
comes out of and, and, and returns
eventually to, to sleep. Uh,
it is, uh, a kind of dream vision, uh,
Don Teske in its, uh, uh, mode,
uh, and, and, and full of 'em here. Um,
powerful. Uh, I am Beck pentameter.
It seemed that out of battle,
I escaped down some profound dult tunnel.
Long sense,
scooped through granites,
which titanic wars had groined
yet also, they're
encumbered sleepers, groaned
too fast and thought
or death to be bustard.
Then as I probed them,
one sprang up and stared with
piteous recognition in fixed eyes,
lifting distressful hands as if to bless
and by his smile I knew that selling
hall by his dead smile,
I knew we stood in hell
with a thousand pains. That
vision's face was grained, hit.
No blood reached there from the upper
ground and no guns thumped or down.
The flues made Moan,
strange friend. I said,
here is no cause to mourn.
None said the other.
Save the undone years,
the hopelessness, whatever
hope is, yours was my life.
Also,
I went hunting wild after the
wildest beauty in the world,
which lies not calm and
i's or braided hair,
but mocks the steady running of the
hour and if it grieves grieves rich lear
than here for by my glee might.
Many men have laughed and of my
weeping something had been left,
which must die now. I
mean the truth. Untold,
the pity of war,
the pity war distilled.
Now men will go content with
what we spoiled or discontent,
boil bloody and be spilled.
They will be swift with
swiftness of the Tigris. None.
We'll break ranks though
nations trek from progress.
Courage was mine and I had mystery.
Wisdom was mine,
and I have mastery to miss the march
of this retreating world into veins
citadels that are not walled.
Then when much blood had
clogged their chariot wheels,
I would go up and wash
them from sweet wells,
even with trues that
lie too deep for taint.
I would have poured my
spirit without stint,
but not through wounds,
not on the assess of war.
Foreheads of men have bled where
no wounds were I and the enemy.
You killed my friend.
I knew you in the star for so you frowned
yesterday through me as you jabbed and
killed I parried but my
hands were loathed and cold.
Let us sleep now.
We'll stop now and move on to poems
written during the same period and
associated with images them on Monday.